Some of you have heard the term Blood Brain
Barrier, and of course, some have not.
But lets just say….you basically have a
brick wall around your brain.
Gives another meaning to being hard headed.
HEYO.
I’m sorry.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Your body is constantly in flux.
From eating, drinking, exercise, whatever,
amino acids and hormones and other chemicals
in your body change in response.
For example, your blood sugar spikes after
you eat a piece of cake.
But there’s one area that you’d want to
remain relatively unchanged, your brain.
So there’s like a fortresses between the
brain and the blood called the blood brain
barrier, or BBB.
So what is this thing?
Shout to Asmon Lacroix on twitter for asking
us this very question! #askdnews
The BBB surrounds blood vessels in the brain
and central nervous system.
It locks down the brain and spinal cord fluid.
It lets the necessary molecules through and
keeps the bad stuff out.
It’s made up of tightly knitted endothelial
cells, enzymes and transporters.
Some people have described it as "a brick
wall” around a vast majority of your brain.
Where each cell of the blood-brain barrier
is a brick and the tight junctions between
them are the mortar."
The BBB allows small molecules like alcohol
to squeeze through and the enzymes and transporters
allow essential nutrients like vitamin c and
omega 3s to cross.
But large molecules and bacteria are kept
out.
This whole system keeps what’s on the inside
stable.
The brain needs specific microenvironments
to function properly.
The brain’s communication system relies
on chemical and electrical signalling between
neurons in a tightly controlled environment
to function.
But conditions like inflammation and HIV can
weaken the barrier.
If a bacteria or virus in the blood stream
were to bypass the BBB and get in the brain,
it would get into the way of that kind of
signalling and things would get thrown way
out of balance.
Brain infections are incredibly rare thanks
to the BBB.
But that also means when someone does get
one, it’s incredibly dangerous and hard
to treat.
While good at keeping out the bad stuff, the
BBB is unfortunately good at keeping out the
good stuff too.
Like potentially life saving medicine.
According to the Royal Chemistry Society,
over 95 per cent of drugs do not show useful
activity in the brain.
Those that do make their way into the brain
are only for conditions like depression, schizophrenia,
and insomnia.
There are ways to bypass the BBB but it’s
complicated and is basically neurosurgery.
Like an intracerebral implantation, which
just like it sounds is an implant put directly
into the cerebrum.
But brain tissue is dense, so it’s hard
for medicines to diffuse through the tissue.
So not ideal.
But there might be a way to tunnel through
the brick wall with sound waves.
Which could help brain tumor patients.
Brain tumors are notoriously hard to treat
or take out with surgery, especially a nasty
one like glioma.
They often leave roots behind.
And chemotherapy can’t cross the BBB, leaving
few options for treatment.
So researchers at Sunnybrook Health Sciences
Centre in Canada did something no one else
has done before.
They opened up the BBB with sound waves to
let chemo in.
Seriously, earlier research published in the
journal Ultrasound in Medicine & Biology found
that tiny air bubbles injected into the blood
stream could open up the BBB enough to let
the good stuff in.
They used low-intensity ultrasound waves to
guide the bubbles to blood vessels near the
BBB.
These sound waves made the bubbles expand
and contract and kind of vibrate.
This vibration jiggled open some of the junctions
between cells in the BBB.
In the case of Sunnybrook research, once openings
in the BBB were made, life-saving chemotherapy
could slip through and finally reach it’s
target.
So our bodies are complicated and weird and
mostly fighting FOR us.
But sometimes we have to work against it,
to save lives.
Speaking of weird body things and blood things,
ever wonder why we have different blood types?
There are a number of different blood types
that a person can have, but what’s the difference
between them all?
Julian has the answer in this episode, right
here
So do you have any other questions about how
the body works?
Let us know down in the comments below or
find us on facebook on twitter and don’t
forget to use the #AskDNews